this is a great question why is creating
an environment for people to work at
their natural best so difficult well
welcome to leadership
um creating an environment for people to
work at their natural best is really
really hard just like being a parent is
really really hard the number of parents
you talk to no one thinks they've got it
right and parents make decisions all the
time they're like oh that's it I've
screwed up my kids well leadership is
the same but the reason we want to
create an environment in which people
can work at their natural best is it's
not only great for them it's great for
the organization it's great for the team
it's all that good stuff that that
increases joy and productivity and
everything else it's a
win-win-win-win-win-win situation when
you can do it but it is difficult
because you're dealing with human beings
and human beings are messy we have egos
we have anxieties we have insecurities
we have Ambitions sometimes they're
they're in conflict with each other
sometimes they're in conflict with the
organization sometimes they're in
conflict with you so it's all a big
fundamentally the reason why creating
environments for human beings to thrive
is difficult is because human beings are
messy that's why no one's an expert in
leadership you're always ever a student
so keep working at it it's always worth
it and the good news is like riding a
bicycle you'll get better and better and
better and better if you keep practicing